das ist eine michael krons und liebe
zuschauerinnen liebe zuschauer eine
ziemlich komplizierte frage die wollen
wir auch gleich in einem interview
klären ganz kurz noch vielleicht das was
da gestern abend in kiel passiert ist
das könnte möglicherweise auch für die
afg eine zeitenwende sein die partei
2013 gegründet da ging es zunächst steil
bergauf mit sehr guten wahlergebnis in
ostdeutschland zenit schien bei den
letzten landtagswahlen schon
überschritten aber jetzt zum ersten mal
einen rausschmiss aus einem landtag in
dem man eben vorher hinein gewählt wurde
was soll uns das sagen das werden wir
dann mit dem bundessprecher den
bundesvorsitzenden der af dem moment
alleine im amt nach dem rücktritt von
jörg morden jahr
paladino kampala der bundessprecher
kogler
war das gestern abend so ein
psychologisches minute ehe dieser
misserfolg dass da was ins rutschen
kommt denn die nächsten beiden
landtagswahlen in niedersachsen und in
nrw da sind ja auch keine hochburgen für
die afg ja ich denke wir müssen jetzt
natürlich dieses ergebnis was natürlich
schwer wiegt das muss man schon sagen
ich bin wirklich absolut enttäuscht dass
wir den wiedereinzug verpasst haben wenn
wir jetzt analysieren
gleichwohl muss man sagen das gehört zum
politischen alltag dazu also auch mal
eine niederlage und das ist jetzt unsere
erste niederlage wo wir wieder aus dem
landtag ausscheiden das gehen anderen
kleineren parteien ebenso wie der fdp
und den grünen zum beispiel im saarland
wo wir den wiedereinzug geschafft haben
also wir werden analysieren woran ist
dort gelegenheit warum wir unsere themen
aber auch unsere person nicht unter die
wähler bringen konnten das ist ja
interessant der als den würde ich von
vielen seiten vorgeworfen sie würde sich
immer weiter radikalisieren der
spitzenkandidat in schleswig holstein
dirk nowitzki hat ja gerade so eine art
an die hecke gegeben also um das seriöse
bürgertum anzusprechen das hat aber
überhaupt nicht funktioniert wir müssen
uns natürlich auch die frage stellen wie
wir als alternative und das wollen wir
ja sein zu den anderen parteien
weiterhin auftreten und auch in
schleswig-holstein aufgetreten sind also
die unterscheidbarkeit zu anderen
parteien zur cdu und zur fdp muss ihm
gegeben sein wir müssen klare positionen
vertreten und auch natürlich die themen
die inhalte die richtig und gut sind wir
haben ein gutes grundsatzprogramm aber
ein gutes wahlprogramm das müssen wir an
den wähler bringen das ist uns
schließlich stellen einfach nicht
gelungen ist es auch der fluch der bösen
tat wenn man sich mal die landesverbände
ihrer partei in baden württemberg in
bremen auch in schleswig-holstein
anbieter haben landtagsfraktionen gleich
nach der wahl ein desaströses bild
abgegeben mal etwas zugespitzt gefragt
wenn die afg nicht möglichst bald aus
dieser pubertären phase ihrer partei
entwicklung rauskommt dann wären sie
solche ernüchterungen wie gestern abend
noch häufiger erleben ja also ich denke
das ist im zehnten jahr dringend geboten
das habe ich auch immer wieder gesagt
dass diese disziplinierung kommen muss
und sie kommt ja auch also baden
württemberg haben sich angesprochen der
landes war man auch die landtagsfraktion
steht wesentlich gefestigter einer neuen
legislatur da und das wird uns auch in
nordrhein-westfalen passieren dann haben
wir einen guten wahlkampf gemacht habe
gute spitzenkandidaten in nordrhein
westfalen und deswegen bin ich auch
zuversichtlich dass wir dort einen
sieben tagen ein gutes ergebnis erzielen
werden am nächsten sonntag sie haben in
der letzten woche in einer pressemeldung
den bundeskanzler aufgefordert sich bei
dem thema das alles beherrscht im moment
auch zum teil den landtagswahlkampf und
wird uns auch noch lange erhalten
bleiben das thema überfall auf die
ukraine krieg in der ukraine sie an den
bundeskanzler letzte woche in einer
pressemeldung aus gefordert deutsche
interessen zu vertreten und keine
schweren waffen in die ukraine zu
liefern wörtlich
sollten ein kriegsverbrecher dort
ungehindert das war ein blutiges
handwerk fortführen wenn das war ja mit
dieser aussage überhaupt nicht gemeint
hier geht es darum dass man die
deutschen interessen natürlich im
vordergrund tritt wie es im übrigen
alles souveränen staaten in europa
touren und das hat ja aber bundeskanzler
scholz am anfang auch gewährleistet
danzinger damit den schlingerkurs an hat
sich von der cdu und für den grünen
treiben lassen unter dem doch dann auf
einmal schwere waffen geliefert was wir
als afd auch als wirklich schweren
fehler halten weil das ist nicht unser
krieg mit russland wir wollen in diesem
konflikt nicht hineingezogen werden und
deshalb müssen wir hier auf unsere
interessen was energiesicherheit zum
beispiel angeht gas öl embargo ist ja
jetzt ein großes thema was die deutsche
wirtschaft treffen wird also wir reden
hier von 10.000 100.000 arbeitsplätzen
und das ist die aufgabe deutscher
politiker wie ich es bin darauf
aufmerksam zu machen und die interessen
deutschland zu vertreten ja aber sind
wir in diesem krieg nicht längst drin
können wir wirklich neutral bleiben
angesichts der bilder aus mario pohl und
krank ist dass man zumindest der ukraine
helfen muss dass sie von putin nicht
platt gemacht wird also ich muss zwar
gesagt wenn ein bisschen erschüttert
wenn wir jetzt schon die totalität
einschlagen wir sind in diesen krieg
drin denn dann haben wir den dritten
weltkrieg das muss jetzt gesagt putin
würde das sehen ob wir klicks pause
das muss uns klar sein ja putin hat die
entscheidung ob wir kriegspartei sind
oder nicht indem wir waffen liefern
hätten wir uns auf eine neutralere seite
geschlagen wie österreich wie aber zum
beispiel auch die ungarn dann käme
überhaupt nicht diese diskussion
überhaupt in den raum also ich denke das
sollten wir um alles in der welt
vermeiden und natürlich endlich die
friedens rhetorik in den vordergrund
stellen ich halte es wirklich für fatal
dass deutsche politiker zum self machen
nach kiel fahren und nicht weiter nach
moskau also dialog und diplomatie muss
auf beiden seiten stattfinden und moskau
man muss versuchen beide verhandlungs-
und kriegsparteien an den tisch setzt
nicht nur so kann man frieden schaffen
kuba ist natürlich völlig irrational mit
herrn putin noch reden zu wollen nachdem
was er angerichtet hat man ja vorher
gerät er ist der kriegstreiber nicht die
westlichen staaten also die usa hat
sicherlich genauso gern anteil an diesen
konflikt wenn man das im nachhinein
betrachtet auch was die usa waffen
weiterhin liefert die europa hier in
diesen krieg hineingezogen und dessen
stellvertreter krieg und was wollen sie
sonst machen außer mit putin reden oder
mit der regierung in moskau wir müssen
versuchen auf der diplomatischen ebene
das diesen konflikt zu entschärfen und
deswegen muss man sich auch mit putin
einen tisch setzen ob uns das gefällt
oder nicht um mir gefällt sicherlich
auch nicht diese angriffskrieg der
russen dort gut das werden wir sehen wie
sich das weiter entwickelt sie haben
jetzt auch eine knappe woche zeit ihren
potenziellen wählerinnen und wählern
unter anderen dieses thema in nordrhein
westfalen zu erklären kommenden sonntag
ist landtagswahl
danach am montag wieder wahlnachlese und
genau in einer woche treffen wir uns
hier wieder werden über die neue
situation sprechen soweit die lokale
bundessprecher der afd ich bedanke mich
liebe zuschauer ma 10 uhr 15 ist die afg
heute mit ihrer pressekonferenz dran
relativ früh am tag da ist dann noch der
spitzenkandidat nobis aus schleswig
holstein mit dabei bei phoenix werden
sie das natürlich mit erleben und ich
gebe jetzt damit zurück zu michael krons
nach bonn